[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد وفي عناوين الحصاد
فرنسا تعلن سحب سفيرها من النيجر
يؤكد وقفه تعاون العسكري مع اليامي وسحب
القوات الفرنسيه بحلول نهايه العام
والمجلس العسكري في النيجيري يعلن اغلاق
المجال الجوي امام الطائرات الفرنسيه
تصعيد اسرائيلي جديد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه جيش الاحتلال يقصف موقعين
لحماس في غزه ويعزز قواته على الحدود مع
القطاع
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم طولكرم في الضفه
الغربيه وتقتل فلسطينيين
بعد ايام بالمواجهات في كندا اصول اول
دفعه من ارمن الاقليم الى ارمينيا رئيس
الوزراء الارميني يقول ان تحالفات بلاده
الحاليه غير مجديه
بتاجيج الصراع
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلنا الرئيس الفرنسي اما نويل ماكرو
عوده السفير الفرنسي من يامي في الساعات
المقبله ورحيل القوات الفرنسيه بحلول
نهايه العام واعلن ماكرون في مقابلات
تلفزيونيه ان فرنسا قررت اعاده سفيرها وان
بلاده ستنهي تعاونها العسكري مع النيجر
مشيرا الى ان الجنود الفرنسيين البالغ
عددهم
1500 جندي سيغادرون النيجر في الاسابيع
والاشهر المقبله وان الاسباب وان الانسحاب
سيكتمل بحلول نهايه العامه
معنا منا باريس ليزني مديره معهد دراسات
العلاقات الدوليه والاستراتيجيه في باريس
اهلا بك سيده ليزلي اذا قرار بسحب السفير
بعد مده طويله من الاصرار على الابقاء على
السفير وعدم الاعتراض بالنظام القائد في
نيابه
ماذا ترجحين بالاسباب ادت الى هذا القرار
من قبل الرئيس الفرنسي باعتقادك
في البدايه انا اعتقد انه خبر سار جدا
الجميع ساره راضيه الان اعتقد ان شعب
النيجر سعيد لانها نهايه فتره طويله من
التوترات لماذا الان لماذا ليس مثلا قبل
اسبوع او منذ البدايه
هذا
الموضوع الرئيس وحده يعرف اعتقد ان المده
طالت ولم يعد بامكانه ان يتحمل هذا الوضع
وبالتالي وجب اعاده الجنود وكذلك هناك خطر
وتهديد على السفير وهو قد يقع في ازمه
وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذا القرار قد تاخر
ولكنني لن
اتوقف عند هذا الموضوع يجب ان نكتفي بان
الخبر صار
باعتقادك ما الذي سينجر على هذا النزول من
الشجره
اعتقد انه كلما مر الوقت
وكلما استقر النظام العسكري الجديد
صعوبه فكره العوده الى الوراء واعاده محمد
بازوم الى منصبه
يصبح ذلك بعيده المدى الاكثر فاكثر وكذلك
تدخل الاكواس لم يعد امرا مطروحا
والتكتيكيه
عمليتين ماليا هذا كله غير قائم ولا يمكن
تنفيذه لم يعد امامه خيار اعتقد انه انتظر
انتظرا انتظره ومن ثم بعد ان استنفذ كافه
الخيارات كافه الاحتمالات لم يعد لديه
مجال سوى ان يتخذ هذا القرار
هنا في فرنسا كثرت الاصوات وعلى هذه
الاصوات التي تطالب بالتخاذ قرار لان
الوضع لم يعد محتملا وقلنا ان بزوم لم يعد
بامكان ان يعود الى السلطه لكن الرئيس قرر
ان يذهب حتى اخر لحظه والان نتحدث عن
نهايه حرب طالت احد عشر عاما في الساحل
ولم تعد فرنسا موجوده في مالي ولا في
النيجر ارجو ان معي سيده لاستقبل ضيفي من
لندن ديفيد لمدير مركز جنيف للامن
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا سيد
ديفيد كيف وجدت هذا القرار من قبل الرئيس
الفرنسي الفرنسي بسحب السفير ومن ثم ايضا
قطع العلاقات العسكريه مع انيامي وبالتالي
نقل القوات الفرنسيه من اليامي
كان هذا قرارا
على الفرنسيين اتخاذه وكانت المساله مجرد
وقت من جانبي الرئيس الفرنسي ارادوا ان
يظهروا الامر وكان القرار جاء من فرنسا
وليس من المجموعه العسكريه الانقلابيه
التي لم يريد الاعتراف بها لكن كان هذا
امرا حادثا لا محاله لان السفير الفرنسي
والقوه الفرنسيه تم عزلها ووضعها في موقف
صعب وايضا
الراي العام في فرنسا بدا يشعرون بان
مساله عوده الرئيس بازون الى سده الحكم لم
تعد قائمه والاكواس غير قادره على التدخل
العسكريا هذه اخبار ساره للشعب النيجر هم
عليهم ال يمضون قدما وعلى المجموعه
العسكريه الانقلابيه عليها ان تقرر
وتستجيب لرغبات الشعب في تنظيم
انتخاباتك سيد ديفيد وابقى معك على ماذا
كان يراهن الرئيس الفرنسي حتى انتظر كل
هذه المده ومن ثم اعلن هذا القرار هذا
اليوم على ماذا كان يراهن
الرئيس الفرنسي ربما كان لا يزال يعتقد
ستتدخل تدخل عسكريا من نوع ما لاعاده
الرئيس بازون ولربما اعاده النظام السابق
لكنهم ادركوا ان هذا لن يحدث وخاصه
وان
البلدان الثلاثه بوركينا فاسو ومالي
والنيجر
وقعوا اتفاقا مشتركا والذي يعني عمليا ان
البلدان الثلاثه مستعده للتدخل في حاله
تعرض اي منهما
لهجوم عسكريين ضده وهذا يجعل من الصعوبه
بمكان اكواس ان تقوم باي تدخل عسكري اذا
بالنسبه لفرنسا هذا هو الخيار الاخير
ولا خيار اخر امامهم سوى سحب قواتهم
والافضل لهم ان يسحبون قواتهم وبحسن نيه
بدلا من سحبها في ظروف اسوء
قلت في قبل قليل بانك مرتاحه لهذا القرار
ولكن هل باعتقادك الرئيس ماكرون مرتاح عقب
هذا القرار
اتواجد في داخل راس الرئيس الفرنسي ولكنني
اعتقد ان هذا القرار وكما لاحظنا جميعا
وحين يتحدث عن
نيجيري يتحدث لمده دقيقتين يتحدث بطريقه
طبيعيه قدر الامكان وفي نفس الوقت
يظهر كانه يتحكم بالامور وبالوضع ولكننا
كلنا مدركون ان هذا القرار لم يكن سهلا
لقد وصلنا الى هذا القرار بعد اسابيع من
النقاشات الجميع كان يقول له ان هذا
القرار قد نضج وتاخر
لا يحتاج ان تكوني في راس الرئيس حتى
تجيبي عليه ولكن فقط سؤالي هو عن انعكاسات
هذه الخطوه على الرئيس الفرنسي ان كانت
ايجابيه سيكون مرتاحا وان كانت سلبيه
فاكيد انه لن يكون مرتاحا ماذا ترجحين
انا لا اعتقد انه بالنسبه الى موضوع
السياسه الداخليه
سوف
يؤثر هذا القرار كثيرا
فالفرنسيون ليس او لم يتابعوا بالضروره عن
كتم ما حصل في النيجر
شكرا بالنسبه لهذا القرار على وجه الخصوص
انا لا اعتقد سيؤثر على الساحه الداخليه
سياسيه الفرنسيه اما خارجيا فالتاثير كبير
طريقه ادارته للازمه في النيجر سوف تؤثر
على
سياستها الخارجيه على علاقته بالرؤساء
الافارقه الاخرين على الثقه التي يليها
نظرائه له اما بالنسبه الى السياسه
الداخليه فلا اعتقد ان تاثير كبير لان
الفرنسيين ليسوا مهتمين كثيرا بهذا
الموضوع هناك الكثير من المشاكل الفرنسيه
في سياسات داخليه ولم يتابع ما يحصل في
النيجر هذا بالنسبه لما يجري في باريس
ماذا عن ما يجري في نيامي وانا سؤال البيت
من لندن السيد ديفيد هل سيعزز هذا القرار
الفرنسي مكانه المجلس العسكري في النيامي
ام ليس بالضروره لم يغلق ملف التوتر
الامني والضغوط على المجلس العسكري في
نيابه حتى عقب هذه الخطوه الفرنسيه ماذا
ترجح
نعم القرار سيحدث سرقا وسوف يبرهن امام
شعب النيجر ان
المجموعه العسكريه الانقلابيه قد عززت
موقفها
وقرارها
بطرد السفير وطرد البعث العسكريه الفرنسيه
قد نجح في النهايه
وهم الان كانت النيجر على راس
العمليات العسكريه في
الساحل وعندما اجمل الفرنسيون على مغادره
مالي وبوركينا فاسو اكدوا للرئيس النيجر
بازون بان بلاده هي القاعده العسكريه
الاهم للفرن الان
بقائهم كان لا يعطي موقفا صلبا للمجموعه
الانقلابيه الان بعد رحيل او قرار طرد
الفرنسيين هذا تشكل ضربه كبيره للعمليات
العسكريه الفرنسيه في افريقيا وسوف يؤثر
على علاقات فرنسا بشكل عام وعلاقاتها
العسكريه
مع الدول القاره وايضا يظهر امام بلدان
مثل الصين وامريكا وروسيا بان الفرن لم
يعودوا موجودين بنفس الزخم من لندن ديفيد
اوتو اندلي مدير مركز جنيف للامن
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا شكرا
لك وكذلك لضيفه من باريس
مديره معهد دراسات العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه في باريس
هذا وكان النظام العسكري الحاكم في النيجر
منع الطائرات الفرنسيه من عبور المجال
الجوي للبلاد بحسب تعميم ارسل الى الطواقم
الجويه نشر الاحد على موقع وكاله الامن
والملاحه الجويه في افريقيا وجاء في
التعميم ان المجال الجوي للنيجر مفتوح
امام جميع الرحلات التجاريه الوطنيه
والدوليه باستثناء الطائرات الفرنسيه او
الطائرات التي تستاجرها فرنسا كما يشير نص
التعميم الى ان المجال الجوي يبقى مغلقا
امام تحليق الطائرات العسكريه سواء تلك
التي تجري عمليات او تلك التي تقوم برحلات
خاصه ما لم تحصل على اذن خاص من السلطات
[موسيقى]
قصف جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نقطتي رصد
لحركه حماس في المناطق الحدوديه وسط وشمال
القطاع وقد ادى القصف لتدمير النقطتي
الرصد دون ان يبلغ عن اصابات ونشر ناشطون
فلسطينيون صورا لنقطتي الرصد التابعتين
لكتائب القسام في غزه عقب الغارات
الاسرائيليه مساء
هذا واعلنت وزاره الصحه بغزه اصابه سته
الشبان فلسطينيين بجروح مختلفه جراء قمع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مظاهرات قرب
الشريط الحدودي شرقي قطاع غزه واطلقت قوه
الاحتلال الرصاص والغاز الموسيله للدموع
باتجاه المتظاهرين وقد اشعل الشبان
المشاركون اطارات مطاطيه قرب السياج
الامني تمديدا بالاعتداءات والاقتحامات
للمسجد الاقصى
في الاثناء اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قرر
تعزيز قواته على الحدود مع القطاع بقوات
اضافيه وذكر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي في
حسابه على منصه اكس انه اجرى تقييما امنيا
في منطقه غلاف غزه مع رئيس الاركان وقاده
العسكريين اخرين كما ذكر المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان المهمه الموكله
للقوات الاضافيه التي تقرر ارسالها الى
حدود غزه هي حمايه السجاء السياج الامنيه
فالضفه الغربيه شيعه فلسطينيون جثماني
الشاهدين اسيد ابو علي وعبد الرحمن ابو
دغش في مخيم نور شمس بطولكرم وكانت قوات
الاحتلال قد اجتاحت مخيمين نور شمس
وطولكرم بعد منتصف الليل بحجه تدبير عبوات
الناسفه جاهزه للتفجير وقد خرجت اليات
الاحتلال الى الشوارع والبناء التحتيه
وخطوط المياه الرئيسيه في المخيم
قتل وخراب ودمار هذا ما يخلفه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عقب كل عمليه عسكريه ينفذها
اخر العمليات هنا في مخيم نور شمس الشرق
مدينه طولكرم تدمير لما تبقى من شوارعه
وبنى تحتيه في مخيم متهالكا للاجئين
الفلسطينيين مزاعم الاحتلال وجود عبوات
جاهزه للتفجير لكن هذه العبوات محليه
الصنع اعطبت اليه عسكريه واصابت جنديا
وانتقاما قتل الاحتلال فلسطينيين عبد
الرحمن ابو دغش واسيد جبعاوي اما العائلات
فلا تملك الا الصبر طلع
اجره رصاص من الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
[تصفيق]
بوحده الصف في الميدان
ومواصله مقاومه ومواجهه الاحتلال الهدف هو
ارام الناس على طرد هؤلاء المقاتلين الهدف
هو القضاء على الحاضن الشعبي للمقاتلين
هنا في هذا الفيلم كل هذا الدمار التي
الذي رايته القتل الذي حدث هنا شهداء
اثنين كله الهدف منه هو القضاء على الحاضن
الشعبيه ولكن ايضا بعد كل عمليه عسكريه
يتضح حجم الاثار النفسيه على العائلات
وتحديدا الاطفال اولادنا مش عارفين يناموا
وخايفين
قاعدين وبرجوا وبالليل طول الليل وهم
قاعدين مش عارفين يناموا خايفات البنات
نفسيتهم تعبانه
ان مقاومتهم لن تتوقف في الوقت الذي تعلو
فيه اصوات على منصه الامم المتحده بضروره
حل الدولتين تمارس ضغوط على الفلسطينيين
لوقف مقاومتهم للاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي
يواصل ليل نهار قتل الفلسطينيين
وتمغي صح حياتهم
من مخيم نور شمس طولكرم
ارحب بضيفيه من حيفا الدكتور سليم بريك
الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي والمحاضر في
العلوم السياسيه ومن غزه الدكتور حسام
الدجني الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكما
ابدا معك دكتور سليم في محاوله
فهم هذا التصعيد الفلسطينيون يقولون ان
هذا التصعيد جزء اساسي من اهداف هذا
التصعيد هو التغطيه على الاعتداءات
والاقتحامات للمسجد الاقصى الى اي مدى هذا
صحيح
مساء الخير نعم اذا حد كبير هذا صحيح هناك
في كل عيد تقريبا في اقتحامات المسجد
الاقصى والتصعيد هو قسم من هذا الموضوع لا
يمكن الفصل ولكن باعتقاده انه التصعيد له
اكبر بكثير اولا تتعلق بثلاث محاور محور
الاول هو تركيبه هذه الحكومه التي تريد
تصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه نهائيا والعوده
الى
اتفاقيات يعني مثلا
ببروتوكول جلسه الحكومه من 30 ثمانها
للموافقه على اتفاقيه اوسلو عادوا الى
مرجعيه وما يسمى الحكم الذاتي الشخصي
المحور الثاني هو طبعا محور التطبيع الذي
اعطى زخم لاسرائيل بالاستمرار في الاعتداء
على الفلسطينيين كما راينا كمان في حدود
غزه وكمان في الضفه الغربي في طولكرم
والمحور الثالث هو
عمليه ركيبه هذه
الحريه فيها جناح فاشي لا
يخفي نواياه اتجاه الشعب الفلسطيني وكما
راينا من
عضوه تجمع الام
وال في فلسطين وهذا
نهي ضخم من التطبيع الذي نراه في الفتره
الاخيره وخصوصا في الايام الاخيره
هذا يشجع اسرائيل على استمرار بهذه
السياسه طيب اذا كانت هذه هي اهداف هذه
الحكومه دكتور حسام ضيفي من غزه تحديدا ما
جرى على الحدود مع قطاع غزه الى اي مدى ما
جرى حتى الان هو ضمن ما يمكن توصفه به
قواعد الاشتباك واذا كانت هذه اهداف
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى اي مدى يمكن
البقاء على هذا الالتزام بقواعد اللعبه
بين الطرفين او قواعد الحرب عفوا
يعني في تقديري ان ما تقوم به اسرائيل مع
قطاع غزه هي ضمن اطار عبد الاصابع مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي لا تريد ان تدخل
في مواجهه عسكريه قد تفسد عليها قطار
التطبيع مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايضا في ظل الاعتبارات الداخليه لبنيامين
نتنياهو ليس بن صالحه ان يدخل في مواجهه
عسكريه بالاضافه الى قدره المقاومه على
التاثير وعدم معرفه نتائج هذه المعركه
وتداعياتها حتى على مستقبل نتنياهو
السياسي ولكن في المقابل هي لا تريد ان
تنصاع للمقاومه التي عندما يعني ذهبت ذهب
الشباب السائر الى منطقه الحدود او الى
منطقه السياج بين قطاع غزه ودوله الاحتلال
كان لهم رسائل ثلاثه مهمه جدا الرساله
الاولى هي رساله يعني وحده ساحات بين غزه
والضفه والقدس والاسرى في ظل اعتداءات
اسرائيل المتكرره على الاسرى وعلى وعلى
الضفه المحتله وايضا رساله ذات طابع
انساني في ظل انقلاب اسرائيل على
التفاهمات التي ابرمت برعايه قطريه ومصريه
واماميه مما تفاقم الواقع الانساني نتكلم
عن اغلاق حاجز بيت حنون لليوم الثامن على
التوالي تقديرات اتحاد العمال في قطاع غزه
اكثر من عشر ملايين دولار خسائر في قطاع
غزه وبذلك الواقع الانساني معادلته مهمه
جدا في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في اطار الهدوء
وبذلك المطلوب الان من المجتمع الدولي لان
يلتفت الى واقع قطع غزه اولا من الناحيه
الانسانيه ثم الواقع السياسي الذي تحاول
اسرائيل ان تفرضه في الضفه الغربيه وفي
القدس وايضا سياسه بن غفير مع ضد الاسرى
الفلسطينيين لذلك اذا تدخل المجتمع الدولي
ممكن ان يحيد القطاع عن معركه عسكريه حتى
وان لم تعيدها اسرائيل ولن تريدها
المقاومه ولم تعمل عليها لان السلوك على
الارض كما تفضلت بسلاله بسؤالك هو القواعد
الاشتباك المقبوله بالنسبه
في ظل اذا ما كان واحد من اهداف هذه
الحكومه هو تجاوز المحرمات بالنسبه للطرف
الفلسطيني الدكتور سليم الى اي مدى بامكان
هذه الحكومه ان تتجاوز المحرمات التي فيها
اتفاق بين مختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه وبين
الحفاظ على هذه الحسابات التي ذكرتها قبل
قليل يعني كيف لها ان تقوم بكل هذه
الحسابات دون ان تفجر برميل البارود في
المنطقه
الغربيه قطاع غزه استراتيجيه الاسرائيليه
والتي حصلت على
دعم العالم طبعا بقياده المتحده واوروبا
هو الحصار على غزه ومن ناحيه اسرائيل
الحصان ممكن يستمر عشرات السنوات كما كان
مثلا الحصار على كوبا اما بالنسبه للضفه
الغربي اسرائيل
هي حماس من السيطره في الضفه الغربيه باي
طريقه باي شكل من الاشكال وثانيا عمليه
السيطره على منطقه ما يعني اسرائيل حاليا
هو ليس التصعيد مع الضفه الغربيه ولكن
ارسال رساله للمقاومين في الضفه الغربيه
بان اسرائيل سترد بيد من حديد لكل محاوله
للمقاومه ولهذا نحن نرى في الفتره الاخيره
ضرب
[موسيقى]
الشوارع ضرب مصادر المياه كل هذه الامور
التي هي عمليه نوع من العقاب
يقوم اي جهه بحضن المقاومه هذا الهدف
الاساسي طبعا
الهدف من وراء
كل هذا لان نتنياهو ما يريده حاليا وما
يراه كهدف
[موسيقى]
ينزل عن الساحه السياسيه هو تصفيه الموضوع
الفلسطيني وتحويله الى نوع من الحكم
الذاتي كما كان نقاش بين بيجن والسادات في
وهو يرى نتنياهو وحكومته الحاليه او قسم
كبير حيث ماده الحاليه ترى للسلطه
الفلسطينيه
ايضا بالنسبه لفصائل المقاومه في قطاع غزه
كيف لها ان تحدث هذه المعادله بين انه لا
لتجاوز الخطوط الحمراء خاصه ما تعلق
بالمسجد الاقصى وبين ايضا ان لا تجر قطاع
غزه وكل ما يعانيه الى حرب مفتوحه قد
خبرها الفلسطينيون في قطاع غزه
يعني هذا يعيدنا الى ما هي خيارات قطاع
غزه وخيارات المقاومه ثلاثه خيارات امام
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اما ان تدخل بالخيار
العسكري من خلال اطلاق القذائف او
الصواريخ الى منطقه الغلاف الى او الى عمق
دوله الاحتلال وهذا سيجر مواجهه عسكريه
على القطاع قد تحرف الانظار عما يجري
بالضفه المحتله الخيار الثاني هو مسيرات
عوده وادوات خشنه مثل ما تقوم به الان
واعتقد انها قررت ان يكون هذا الخيار هو
الامثل في هذا التوقيت وخيار المسيرات
السلميه في قلب المدن وهو يعني معمول به
منذ فتره وبتقديري ان المقاومه في هذه
اللحظه هي لا تستبعد السيناريو العسكري
ولكن تحاول ان تراقب المشهد بالضفه
الغربيه والمشهد ايضا على جبهه الشمال مع
لبنان ضمن اطار تنسيق مشترك مع المحور
المقاومه ككل لانه اي معركه مع قطاع غزه
كما قلت قد تستنزف المقاومه في هذا
التوقيت هي تطرحها في اطار الر على دوله
الاحتلال ولكن هي لا تحبذها كما هو
نتنياهو ايضا قد لا يحبذها في هذا التوقيت
للكوابح التي ذكرتها قبل قليل عينه على
انجاز التطبيع مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهذا يستحوذ على اعلى اولوياته
بالاضافه الى الاعياد اليهوديه اليوم وغدا
ونهايه هذا الشهر واول الشهر القادم ايضا
موضوع الوضع الداخلي في اسرائيل يشكل ايضا
هو كابع وايضا رد فعل المقاومه على هذه
العدوان في حال اندلعت مواجهه عسكريه
اعتقد انهم كوابح مهمه بالنسبه لنتنياهو
من غزه دكتور حسام والمحلل السياسي ومن
حيث الدكتور سليم ببريك الخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي والمحاضر في العلوم السياسيه
شكرا جزيلا لكما
نقلت وكاله عن مسؤول الفلسطينيين قوله ان
وفدا سعوديا سيزر رام الله خلال الاسبوع
الجاري وانه من المقرر ان يلتقي بالرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس واضاف المسؤول
الفلسطيني ان المبعوث السعودي غير المقيم
نايف بن بندر السديري سيراس الوفد السعودي
واشارت رويترز الى ان زياره الوفد السعودي
لرام الله تاتي وسط مساع دبلوماسيه للتوصل
الى اتفاق بين السعوديه واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
الى اقليمي يا كارابا الذي يشهد تطورات
عده فقد قالت الحكومه الارمينيه ان الف
وخمسين شخصا عبروا الى البلاد من الاقليم
وبالتزامن مع بوادر توتر بين روسيا
وارمينيا بشان الصراع في الاقليم ذكرت
وسائل اعلام ارمينيه ان هناك تحضيرات لعقد
مباحثات بين رئيس اذربيجان ورئيس وزراء
ارمينيا مطلع اكتوبر المقبل
حركه على لاتشين المعبر الشهير ممر لا بد
منه لمغادير اقليم كاراباخ نحو ارمينيا
اغلب العابرين هم ارمن الاقليم
اثر مغادره ما يسمونها ارضاهم التاريخيه
على العيش على ارض معترف بها دوليا جزءا
من اذربيجان
التي حسمت الخلافه الطويله الدامي على
كاراباخ لصالحها تعهدت بحمايه حقوق
المنتمين الى عرقيه الارمن مع ذلك تصل
اولى دفعات المغادرين من هؤلاء الخائفين
على مصائرهم الى ارمينيا ترافقهم قوات حفظ
السلام الروسيه هي ذاتها القوات التي
انجزت اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في كراباخ
وهي ذاتها التي تشكك الان لرضاعا في
اهدافها هذا نقودسونا تحليل الوضع يظهر ان
المنظمات الامنيه والحلفاء الذين نعتمد
عليهم منذ الزمن طويل قد كلفوا بمهمه
اظهار ضعفنا واستحاله ان تكون لشعب
ارمينيا دوله مستقله ان المنظمات الامنيه
التي تشارك فيها ارمينيا غير فعاله في
حمايه امن البلاد ومصالحها من الاتجاه
المعاكس ياتي اللوم الروسي لقاده ارمينيا
انهم يؤججون الصراع في كاراباخ
حقيقه في ارمينيا كما هو الحال في عدد من
بلدان الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق الاخرى
هناك لوبي قوي لتعزيز مصالح الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وهم يعملون على تقويض
نفوذ روسيا هناك وهذه حقيقه ومن المؤسف ان
القياده الارمينيه تعمل على صب الوقود على
النار
لن تنهي كلماته الجدل القائم اساسا في
رضاعه حول جدوى تحالفاتها الاقليميه
وحتما لن ينتهي قريبا ذاك الجدل المتعلق
باداره نزاع كرباخ يتحدث مجلس الامن
القومي الارميني عن احباط محاوله
للاستيلاء على السلطه في البلاد واعتقال
اشخاص على صله بالقضيه
ثم اعتقالات اخرى في ارمينيا ما تزال
تطاول متظاهرين رافضين للتعامل حكومه رئيس
الوزراء نيكول باشنيان مع قضيه ارمن كرباخ
هل طوي الملف يبدو ان هناك متسعا لمشاورات
سياسيه بشان مستقبل الاقليم وشعبه
وسائل اعلام ارمينيه رجحت ان مباحثات
ستجمع باشنيان
في مطلع اكتوبر المقبل
هذا وقال المكتب الاعلامي في الرئاسه
الاذربيجانيه انه تم فصل عاصمه اقليم
كاراباخ عن نظام الطاقه في ارمينيا وربطها
بنظام الطاقه في اذربيجان ونشر المكتب
الاعلامي مقطعا مصورا قال انه يظهر العمل
اثناء عمليه الربط وبعد الانتهاء
هذا وتواصلت الاحتجاجات المطالبه باستقاله
رئيس الوزراء الارميني نيكولا على خلفيه
الاحداث الاخيره في اقليم كاراباخ ورفع
المحتجون وسط العاصمه يريفان شعارات
مناهضه لسياسات الحكومه الارمينيه في
اداره ازمه كاباخ مراسل الجزيره رصد جانبا
من المظاهرات التي خرجت في
اليوم الخامس على توالي تواصل المعارضه
الارمنيه وانصار المعارضه بالاضافه الى
المحتجين الغادرين سجاجاتهم واسطه العاصمه
الارمنيه
في تسير ازمه كهربا كانت المعارضه قد
توعدت بان هذه المظاهرات ستكون الاكبر من
نوعها لكن يمكن القول بان الاعداد لم تزد
عن اعداد المحتاجين الذين شاركوا في
المظاهرات التي
شهدتها ساحه الجمهوريه وايضا شوارع
العاصمه الارمينيه خلال اليومين الماضيين
طبعا المطالب واضحه وهي استقاله رئيس
الوزراء نيكولب بالاضافه الى فتح
ممرات من اجل اخراج سكان
اقليم كاراباخ من الارمن الى داخل الاراضي
الارمنيه وانصار المعارضه
يدعون الى
احتجاجات اخرى
غدا وذلك طبعا لمواصله هدف الضغط الشعبي
على حكومه
اكثر من مره على انه لا ينوي الاستقلال
لكنه في المقابل اكد استعداد حكومته
للتعامل مع هذه الازمه تنفيذا للاتفاق مع
الجانب الازرق
ام الجزيره
[موسيقى]
ومن باكو البروفيسور باريس اسماعيل زاده
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه ونائب رئيس جامعه
ابا اهلا بكم ابدا معك سيده من الشريان
حتى الان اكثر من 99% من الارمن في اقليم
كنباخ عبروا عن رغبتهم في مغادره الاقليم
ان يخرجون الاقليم اليوم فقط اكثر من الف
منهم خرجوا باتجاه ارمينيا كيف سيتم
التعامل مع هذه القنبله البشريه الموقوته
من قبل ريفان
منزله الا اذا كان مهددا بحياته وكان يعذب
باستمرار ويتم تشويحه قطع راسه
وكل انواع الكوابيس التي لا يمكن الا ان
نتخيلها ولا نتخيل انها تحصل في القرن
الحادي والعشرين
اسماعيل ايضا ما ينقل من داخل اقليم كنباخ
ان من يريدون الخروج من الارمله من
الاقليم انهم يخافون من التطهير العرقي
استبعت الى ضيفه تقول بانه يتم اخراجهم
بالقوه بوضع المسدسات على رؤوسهم هل هذا
ما يجري من وجهه نظركم
للاسف هذا كذب لان الحكومه في اذربيجان
قالت اكثر من مره انهم مواطنون في
اذربيجان اليوم وفرنا 40 طنا من المساعدات
الغذائيه
وطبيه والكهرباء والوقود هناك الكثير من
الصور والفيديوهات اللي في اذربيجان تظهر
ان هناك ارسال مساعده انسانيه طبيه
وغذائيه وغيرها هؤلاء الاشخاص مواطنون في
اذربيجان واسع تحميهم الحكومه
الاعضاء في تشكيلات العسكريه غير الشرعيه
التي قاتلت الدوله في اذربيجان وطالقت
مساعدات عسكريه غير مشروعه من ارمينيا هم
فقط يتوقع منهم ان يغادروا لانهم
لا يخضعون للقوات النظاميه الاذربيجانيه
وقالت لهم الحكومه انهم يمكنهم ان يغادروا
بكل حريه ولكن باقي المواطنين هم اكثر من
مرحب بهم يمكنهم ان يبقوا ويتم توفير
مساعدات الغذائيه له من قبل الحكومه
لدربانيه لجنه دوله بالاحمر قوات مساعده
روسيه اليوم لقد شكلت الحكومه
اذا كانت الصوره كما تصفها ما الذي يدفع
فقط هذا اليوم اكثر من الف خرجوا وهم
يعلمون بانهم يخرجون الى المجهول ارمينيا
لا تستطيع ان توفر لهم السكن الشتاء قادم
وهم يتوجهون نحو ظروف صعبه ما الذي يدفع
هؤلاء الى الخروج بهذه الصوره ايضا
هناك الكثير من البروباجاندا والتهويل
الذي ياتي من الحكومه الارنيه من مجموعات
من الشوطات الارمنيه ولكن دعونا لا ننسى
ان ارمينيا قد
ابقت عشره الاف من الجنود ونتحدث هنا عن
اشخاص مرتبطين بالجنود باسرهم والان
يغادرون الاراضي لان لا يمكنها ان تتحمل
هذه التشكيلات
العسكريه غير الشرعيه على ارمينيا ان تسحب
تشكيلاتها ومجموعاتها
المعسكره غير الشرعيه وبالتالي سوف تبسطوا
سيادتها الدستوريه على هذه المنطقه وسوف
تتولى كافه الامور الخاصه بالمساعدات
الانسانيه وغيرها في المقابل سيده مريم
ضيفتي ما مصلحه باكو ان تمارس
التطهير العرقي ضد من تعتبرهم مواطنين
اذربيجانيين ام ان الان تستثمر في هذا
البعد الانساني بعد من هزمت بشكل او باخر
طبعا فيما جرى في اقليم كاراباخ وهذا
المصير
حاليا لارمينيا حكومه
لم يسبق لها في ثلاثين سنه الاخيره
عن دعمت
اي حوار او اي علاقات وديه مع دول مثل
اذربيجان ولكن بالرغم من ذلك نرى ان الوضع
قد تصعد سريعا ما لا يقوله سعاده
البروفيسور
ومن المفارقه انه يقول اننا نهتم بمواطنين
من خلال اللجنه الدوله الصليب الاحمر
ومساعدات انسانيه دوليه هذا يعني انه
محرومون من حقوقهم الاساسيه بالحركه
بالتنقل بالحياه بالتعلم في اخر تسعه اشهر
يعيشون تحت حصار في مجاعه وليس لديهم اي
امدادات اساسيه هكذا تهتم اذربيجان
بمواطنها
اعذريني على المقاطعه كيف لحكومه مركزيه
ان تتصرف داخل اقليم يحمل السلاح ويدعو
للانفصال
السؤال الشعب لا يريدون ان يعيشوا تحت
سيطره اذربيجان وهم اعتادوا على الناس في
19 من سبتمبر قاموا بقصف
بلدات مسالمه وثم قالوا لهم تعالوا
واعيشوا معنا بسلام الانترنت مليء بجنود
اذربيجانيين يقومون بتشويه اطفال عمرهم 10
سنوات يقطعون رؤوس الناس من يثق بها هكذا
حكومه وبجيش وبيعها كذا دوله ليعيش فيها
يجب ان تدركوا
افتش على جوجل عن الرئيس هو
يكره
وجود ارميه يعتبرها غرب اذربيج كيف يمكننا
ان ننطق بهكذا جيران دعوا انفسكم مكان
هؤلاء الاشخاص من يختار ان يغادرا منزله
ايضا تحمل الانترنت ايضا صور اخرى لوجهه
النظر الاخرى وهنا اسال ضيفي البروفيسور
باريس عن هذا اللقاء المرتقب طبعا بعد
ايام الرئيس الاذربيجاني مع رئيس الوزراء
الارميني الى اي مدى هذا اللقاء مهم في
تجنب كارثه انسانيه او ما قد يطرا من
تطورات نتيجه هذا الوضع في اقليم كهربا
اريد القول ان زميلتي الارمنيه للاسف
تتفوه باكاذيب
ونتحدث عن مليون ادر بيجاني حرمتهم
ارمينيا من منازلهم في العام اربعين
واحتلت طريقه غير مشروع عشنا في المئه من
اراضي اذربيجان اراضي معترف بها دوليا
تعتبرها اربع قرارات عموميه جزءا من
اذربيجان لماذا لا تحدث عن مليون
اذربيجاني لا يعيشون في مخيمات لماذا
نتحدث عن التطهير العرق الذي ارتكبت
ارمينيا بحقائق اذربيجان ماذا عن سؤالي
فيما يتعلق باللقاء المرتقب بين القيادتين
الزعماء قريبا اجنده السلام هذه تستند الى
الاعتراف المشارك
على الاراضي على ارمينيا ان تنسحب ان
تحترم الحوت المعترف فيها الدوليا
وسيادات اذربيجان على اراضيها
ونائب رئيس جامعه
الكاتبه والمحلله السياسيه
[موسيقى]
اكدت شرطه كوسوفو ان قواتها قتلت ثلاثه
مسلحين وسيطرات على دير تحصن او سيطره على
دير تحصل فيه اخرون كانوا ضمن مجموعه شنت
هجوما على موقع للشرطه شمالي البلاد وقتلت
ضابط شرطه وكانت السلطات اعلنت ان مجموعه
من المسلحين الملثمين قطعوا طريقا محليا
في احدى القرى الشماليه وبداوا باطلاق
النار عشوائيا بدوره ابدت قوته او بدورها
ابدت قوه في الاقليم استعدادها للتدخل
تفاصيل متابعه في التقرير التالي
حادث خطير وقع عند الحدود بين صربيا
وكوسوفو شرطه
لهجوم مسلح من قبل ملثمين يستقلون مركبتين
ثقيلتين وصلوا الى قريه بنيسكا شمال
البلاد وبداوا باطلاق النار على وحدات
الشرطه
فتوالت ردود الفعل السياسيه رئيسه كوسوفو
وصفت الهجوم بالارهابي المدبر وقال رئيس
الحكومه ان الجريمه المنظمه تهاجم كوسوفو
اكثر من عقدين مره على انتهاء الحرب ولم
يستقر السلام في كوسوفو بعد سياسيا تتلبد
الاجواء بحالات تصعيد داخلي بين العرقيات
ومع الجوار تحديدا مع صربيا حالات توتر
بدت في الاونه الاخيره اكثر تكرارا
جذور الازمه متشابكه تعود للعقد الاول من
القرن العشرين تفاقمت مع انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي والحرب الدمويه في البلقان بعدها
بسنوات عام 2008 اعلن البرلمان في كوسوفو
استقلال جمهوريه كوسوفو وكان على صربيا
تطبيع علاقتها مع كوسوفو لكنها رفضت
الاعتراف بالجمهوريه واعتبرتها اقليما
منشقا عن بيل غراد تم الاعتراف بكوسوفو من
قبل 97 دوله في الامم المتحده
واثنتين وعشرين دوله من الاتحاد الاوروبي
في ايار مايو الماضي جرت انتخابات محليه
اعتبرت مثيره للجدل وسط مقاطعه واسعه من
صرب كوسوفو شمال البلاد
في تلك الانتخابات اقترع الالبان ما ادى
الانتخاب رؤساء مجالس محليه من الالبان في
مناطق ذات غالبيه صربيه
غضب السرب واعتبروها محاوله لطردهم من
كوسوفو حسب وصفهم وبدت واحده من اسوا
الاضطرابات في شمال كوسوفو منذ سنوات مع
خروج مظاهرات ووقوع اعمال شغب عنيفه نفذها
متظاهرون الصرب
وتتهم الصربيا بتحريض الصرب كوسوفو على
تحدي السلطات برشتينا تدخل المجتمع الدولي
في وساطه بين بلغراد وبرشتينا قبلت
بموجبها كوسوفو الغاء نتائج الانتخابات
وحل المجالس خفتت الازمه لكن من الواضح
انها لم تنتهي
معنى منا لندن
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
ويسمينستر والباحث في شؤون البلقان
بروفيسور ايضا كيف وجدت هذا التطور الامني
هذا اليوم
وهذه محاوله واضحه من قبل
جنود وميليشيات صربيا مدربه تدريبا جيدا
وهذا واضح ان تعتدي على شرطه
وقتلت احد
افراد الشرطه هذا جزء من حمله اوسع
انطلقت منذ اشهر وربما سنوات من اجل
تقويدي عمل حكومه كوسوفو ومحاوله اعاده
كوسوفو تحت السيطره الصربيه للاسف
حتى الان لسنا اكيدين ممن هو الضالع ولكن
يبدو ان
من
ارتكب او ضالع في هذه الحادثه ليس فقط
عصابات محليه بل يبدون مدربين مجهزين
ويبدو انه تم ايقافهم وهم يحاولون نقل
اسلحه في الساعات الفجر الاولى الى كوسوفو
هذا كله يندرج ضمن سرديال ان الصرب في
كوسوفو يعملون مع حكومه صربيا من اجل
تقويدي الامن والسلم في كوسوفو من اجل خلق
نزاع جديد اذا كنا امام اهداف بعيده كما
ذكرت بروفيسور تكرار هذه المحاولات
باعتقادك سيؤدي الى ماذا
الوضع الميداني في كوسوفو بصوره عامه ولا
سيما في شمال متوتر جدا الصرب والالبان
هم في حاله تاهب واي حادثه ولو صغيره قد
تخرج عن السيطره للاسف شهدنا ذلك يتكرر من
قبل
في الماضي ولكن القلق الاساسي هو ان هناك
بعض الاشخاص في حكومه بلغراد هم فعلا
يسعون الى ان يحصل عنف في كوسوفو اما
حكومه كوسوفو فهي بكل بساطه تريد الامن
والاستقرار والسلم في كوسوفو ليس لديها اي
طموحات من اجل ان تجتاح صربيا او ان تعتدي
على اي من الدول المجاوره الطرف الوحيد في
المنطقه الذي يعيد الترسيم الحدود ان يسبب
بانعدام الاستقرار فهي حكومه صربيا تفعل
ذلك في البوسنه وفي كوسوفو وايضا في دول
اخرى ولكن لا شك في ان او الواضح ان تفعل
تريد ان تجد داريعه
ان تحصل بعض اعمال العنف وبالتالي حكومه
كوسوفو ترسل الشرطه تتدخل وتقول حكومه
صربيا وجب علينا ان ندخل لنحميه الصرب
المحليين
ويريدون اعاده القوات الصربيه الى كوسوفو
وهذا بالتحديد ما حصل في تسعينيات
خلال حقبه ميلوسوفيتش
ودفع ميله
لتجهيز الصرف في البوسنه بالاسلحه
وانكر طبعا انه فعل ذلك
هناك قوات للنيت موجوده هل هذا يدخل في
حسابات الطرف السربي اذا كانت هذه هي
حساباته
قوات حفظ السلام التابعه اذا طبعا يجب ان
تكون مشاركه في حفظ السلم والامن في
كوسوفو قد تعرضت الاعتداءات من قبل عصابات
صربيه
قبل اشهر حين حاولت التدخل لحمايه
الرؤساء البلديات المنتخبين حديثا في شمال
كوسوفو نامل انه اذا زادت اعمال العنف سوف
تتدخل قوه الناتو ولكن للاسف كثر في قصفه
وكثر ممن يفهمون ما يحصل بداوا يفقدون
الامل في
هذه القوات تابعه للنيتو يبدو ان يتراجعت
وهناك الكثير ننتقل للاستخباريه التي تشير
ايضا فقد ادركنا الوقت ايضا الاستاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر محليه في ليبيا ان فرق الانقاذ
انتشلت نحو 300 جثه من مناطق بحريه مختلفه
وبينما يقترب عدد المتوفين المسجلين من
4000 شخص تواجه السلطات الليبيه صعوبات في
تحديد هويات الموتى خاصه مع مرور الوقت
ونقص المعدات والوسائل
اسبوعان مر على كارثه السيول في الشرق
الليبي وما تزال فرق الانقاذ تصل الليل
بالنهار بحثا عن جثث الضحايا تحت الطم
والركام وفي مياه البحر المتلاطمه وفق
مصادر محليه في ليبيا فان الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه سجلت انتشال فرق الغوص
نحو 300 جثه من مناطق بحريه مختلفه لا
سيما مدينه درنه شبه المدمره العثور على
مزيد الجثث يرفع عداد القتل في تلك
المناطق المنكوبه كل ساعه وحين انه الان
يقارب 4000 شخص وهذا العدد يتعلق فقط
بالذين سجلتهم وزاره الصحه قبل دفنهم ولا
تعرف على وجه الدقه اعداد الذين دفنوا
عشوائيا وفي مقابر جماعيه مخافه انتشار
الاوبئه كما لا يمكن تحديد اولئك
المفقودين وهم الاف منهم من جرفتهم السي
ول الى البحر واخرون دفنوا تحت الانقاض
التي تغطي احياء بكاملها في درنه
ومع مرور الوقت تتعقد مهمه الجميع ففرق
الاغاثه تواجه تحدي الوصول الى الجثث
البعيده في عمق المياه وتحت ركام المباني
المنهاره اما الجهات الطبيه والعدليه
فامامها معضله تحديد هويات الموتى وتلك
دونها عقبات فنيه
ولوجيستيه وسواها وعلى الصعيد الاغاثي
يستمر تدفق المساعدات المحليه والعربيه
والدوليه الى درنه والمدن المجاوره حيث
تسببت الفيضانات في نزوح اكثر من 43 الف
شخص بحسب احدث احصاء للمنظمه الدوليه
للهجره
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه اعلنت
الوصول نحو ثمان سفن واكثر من 70 طائره
محمله بالمعونات من 24 بلدا حيث حطت خلال
الساعات الماضيه طائره مساعدات صينيه
وطائرتان قطريتان في مطار بنينه في مدينه
بنغازي
قال محمد الجارح المتحدث باسم لجنه
الطوارئ في درنه ان العدد الكلي لحاله
الوفاه التي تم توثيقها لدى وزاره الصحه
وصل الى 3000
و3368 واضاف الجارح في مؤتمر صحفي ان
العدد الاجمالي لم يتم حصره حتى الان وما
زال مرشحا للارتفاع في الايام القادمه
عدد جتامين التي تم انتشالها ودفنها هي 23
جثمان
في مدينه درنه ليصل بذلك العدد الكلي الى
ثلاثه الاف وثمانمائه وثمانيه وستين
حاله موثقه لدى وزاره الصحه ومره اخرى
مساله الارقام والاحصائيات
ما زالت في طور الفرز والتنظيم الارقام
التي اعلن عنها في المؤتمر الصحفي هي
ارقام وزاره الصحه وبكل تاكيد هذا الرقم
سيكون قابل للارتفاع وربما بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
قالت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجينا
ميلوني انها كانت تامل تحقيق نتائج افضل
في ضبط الهجره غير الشرعيه التي سجلت
ارتفاعا كبيرا في بلادها خلال الاشهر
الماضيه وقالت ميلوني في مقابله تلفزيونيه
انها كانت تامل بنتائج افضل مما تحقق رغم
الجهود الكبيره بذلت وقد وافق الاتحاد
الاوروبي على ضخ اموال جديده من اجل الحد
من الهجره التي شهدت تصاعدا ملحوظا خلال
العام الحالي
مر يوم دون ان يقذف المتوسط ضيوفا الى
القاره الاوروبيه فهذه المشاهد شقت الصف
الاوروبيه فيما يبدو الخارجيه الالمانيه
قالت ان مساعده الناس في عرض البحر واجب
انساني واخلاقي لكن روما منزعجه من السلوك
الالماني بل تراه مقوضا لسياساتها تجاه
طالب اللجوء قبل ايام وقفت رئيسه وزراء
ايطاليا على مسرح الامم المتحده وكانت
مشاغلها واضحه
كيف لمنظمه مؤسسه على الكرامه الانسانيه
ان تتغاضى عن كون تهريب البشر اصبح اعلى
ربحا من تهريب المخدرات ان افريقيا ليست
فقيره بل غنيه جدا
وصلت اعداد طالب اللجوء هذا العام الى 130
الف مقابل 70 الفا في العام الماضي كله
حقيقه جعلت معظم الاوروبيين يشددون لهجتهم
تجاه الضيوف الاتين غالبا عبر جزيره
لامبيوزا الايطاليه
فرنسا لن ترحب بالمهاجرين الاتيين من
لامبيوشا ثمت مشكله هجره في فرنسا
وايطاليا وبقيه اوروبا والحل ليس في
استقبال مزيد وقد قلنا لاصدقائنا
الايطاليين اننا مستعدون لمساعدتهم في
اعاده المهاجرين الى بلدانهم التي تربطنا
بها علاقات دبلوماسيه
قبل اسابيع وصل ثمانيه الاف وخمسمئه طالب
لجوء الى لمبيدوزا في ثلاثه ايام فقط مما
جعل ايطاليا تستنجد بالاتحاد الاوروبي
الذي اعلن تكفيف جهوده من خلال ارسال
اموال الى تونس التي ياتي منها كثير من
تلك القوارب ضيق الاوروبيين بالايدي
الانسانيه الممتده لطالب اللجوء في عرض
البحر جعل البابا يتحدث من مارسيليا
محاولا ايقاظ ضمائر الساسه الاوروبيين
حياتنا وحياه الفرنسيين والاوروبيين اليوم
بحاجه الى دفقات من الايمان والصدقه
والامل
مواعظ البابا وتلميحاته لن تلقى غالبا
اذانا صاغيه فمعظم ساسه اوروبا اليوم
وصلوا الى السلطه من خلال خطاب متوجس من
الاخر والاخرين ومن الهجره والمهاجرين
لا تسعى الى امتلاك سلاح نووي واكد رئيس
خلال مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ام برنامج
طهران النووي ان برنامج طهران النووي سلمي
وانها تعاونت بشكل كامل مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
كان هدفنا التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه والوكاله تدرك اننا تعاونا
معها بشكل كامل وبعده طرق ومنذ الاتفاق
النووي صرحت 15 مره بعدم وجود انحرافات من
اي نوع في النشاط النووي الايراني فهو
مدني محض ومخصص للاغراض السلميه وقد اعلنا
مرارا ان استخدام اسلحه الدمار الشامل لا
مكان له لدينا واننا لا نؤمن به ولا حاجه
لنا اليه انما نؤمن به هو الفتوى التي
اصدرها سماحه المرشد الاعلى الخميني بان
استخدام هذه الاسلحه حرام لانه يمكن ان
يؤدي الى مقتل الكثير من الارواح البريئه
[موسيقى]
اصبرون معكم في الحصاد وفي العناوين
فرنسا تعلن سحب سفيرها من النيجر
يؤكد وقف التعاون العسكري مع اليامي وسحب
القوات الفرنسيه بحلول نهايه العام
والمجلس العسكري في النيجيري يعلن اغلاق
المجال الجوي امام الطائرات الفرنسيه
تصعيد اسرائيلي جديد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه جيش الاحتلال يقصف موقعين
لحماس في غزه ويعزز قواته على الحدود مع
القطاع
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم طولكرم في الضفه
الغربيه وتقتل فلسطينيين
بعد ايام بالمواجهات في كندا اصول اول
دفعه من ارمن الاقليم الى ارمينيا رئيس
الوزراء الارميني يقول ان تحالفات بلاده
الحاليه غير مجديه وموسكو تتهم مقاده
ارمينيا بتاجيج الصراع
وفي اطلاله رياضيه بالحصاد تتابعون
ليفربول يفوز على ويسترن يونايتد بثلاثه
اهداف لهدف وتعادل بهدفين لمثلهما بين
ارسنال وتوتنهام وخساره تشيلسي على ارضه
بهدف امام استون فيلا في ابرز مباريات امس
الاحد ضمن الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
[تصفيق]
بهدف تتغير
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان
السفير الفرنسي في نياملي سيعود الى فرنسا
كما اعلن في مقابله تلفزيونيه ان القوات
الفرنسيه ستغادر النيجر بحلول نهايه العام
السلطه الشرعيه الوحيده في النيجر يمثلها
الرئيس بازوم الذي انتخبه شعبه واصبح
اليوم رهيدا
قررت فرنسا سحب سفيرها وبالتالي سيعود مع
العديد من الدبلوماسيين الى فرنسا في
الساعات القادمه وسننهي تعاوننا العسكري
مع سلطات الامر الواقع في النيجر لانها لم
تعد ترغب في مكافحه الارهاب
هذا وكان نظام العسكري الحاكم في النيجر
منع الطائرات الفرنسيه من عبور المجال
الجوي للبلاد بحسب تعميم ارسل الى الطواقم
الجويه نشر الاحد على موقع وكاله الامن
والملاحه الجويه في افريقيا وجاء في
التعميم ان المجال الجوي للنيجر مفتوح
امام جميع الرحلات التجاريه الوطنيه
والدوليه باستثناء الطائرات الفرنسيه او
الطائرات التي تستاجرها فرنسا كما يشير نص
لتعميم الى ان المجال الجوي يبقى مغلقا
امام تحليق الطائرات العسكريه سواء تلك
التي تجري عمليات او تلك التي تقوم برحلات
خاصه ما لم تحصل على اذن خاص من السلطات
معنا من طنجه محفوظه ولد السالك الكاتب
الصحفي المختص في الشؤون الافريقيه سيد
محفوظ كيف وجدت
هذه الخطوه وهذا القرار الفرنسي وطبعا
وابرزها سحب السفير
مرحبا هذا القرار يعني جاء نتيجه للضغط
سواء من طرف الشعب النيجري او من طرف حتى
المجلس العسكري النيجري بطبيعه الحال
مدعوما من طرف بعض انظمه الدول الجوار
التي سبق ان طردت فرنسا كما هو حال مالي
وايضا بوركينا فاسو لتالي اعتقد انه
النتيجه لاستمرار الضغط وعدم ايضا التدخل
المجموعه الاقتصاديه للدول الغربي افريقيا
الذي كان منتظرا من الناحيه العسكريه كل
هذا جعل ان فرنسا تجد نفسها امام امر
الواقع وبالتالي لم يعد امامها سوى قرار
الانسحاب فرنسا كانت تصر على بقاء سفيرها
على اساس انها لا تعترف بقرارات من قاموا
بالانقلاب وتعترف بشرعيه الرئيس بازوم
وتطالب بعودته اليوم الرئيس الفرنسي يقول
نسحب قواتنا لان من يحكمون اليامي الان
ليسوا مستعدين للتعاون فيما يتعلق بمكافحه
الارهاب ماذا عن هذا الخطاب الجديد في
مقابل العلل السابقه
واضح ان رهانات فرنسا خاسره لان هذا
الخطاب كان تكتيكيا وليس استراتيجيا وكانت
فرنسا تقوله علنا لكنها يعني تعتمد بشكل
او باخر على ان يكون هناك تدخل عسكري من
طرف المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول الغربيه
افريقيا بناء على ما سبق ان حصل في يعني
دول اخرى وفي حالات مشابهه حين وكان حين
سيكون التدخل العسكري كان سيكون مسنودا
بطبيعه الحال من طرف فرنسا وبالتالي كان
هناك خطابا احدهما علنيه يتمثل في عدم
الاعتراف بالشرعيه الانقلابيين والقرارات
الصادره عنهم وفي نفس الوقت الدفع
بالمجموعه الاقتصاديه الدول الغربيه
افريقيا من اجل التدخل واعاده نظام بازوم
الى السلطه الان اتضح ان هذا الخيار يعني
خاسرا وبان المجموعه الاقتصاديه الدول
الغربيه افريقيا تتلكى في قرارها التدخل
العسكري وفرنسا سبق ان اعلنت على لساني
ماكرون ان السفيرها لم يعد يجد من الطعام
بعد الحصص الغذائيه المقدمه من يعني
القوات الفرنسيه بالتالي كل هذه الضغوط
جعلت فرنسا تجد نفسها امام خيار يعني سحب
السفير خصوصا وانه في داخل الفرنسي تتعالى
الاصوات يعني على الصعيد السياسي على
الصعيد الشعبي بضروره ان يتخذ قرار كهذا
لان فرنسا يعني
يمرض انفها ان صح التعبير يوميا في بلدان
الساحه الافريقي وفي النيجر بصوره خاصه
القرار لا ننسى انه جاء ساعات بعد قرار
السلطات العسكريه في ميامي يعني حظر
مجالها الجوي على الطائرات الفرنسيه
من طرف فرنسا ما الذي سيختلف في التعاطي
مع هذا الملف ملف النيج الذي بدا بحاله
تصعيد خارجيه كبرى وصلت الى التهديد
بالتدخل العسكري وما الت اليه الامور على
سبيل المثال ما جرى هذا اليوم بسحب السفير
وسحب القوات
اعتقد بان يعني المجلس العسكري الحاكم في
النيجر يعني يكسب خطوات جديده سبق ان كسب
بعض الخطوات الاخرى ممثله في يعني التعاطي
الامريكي وان بحذر ولكن الولايات المتحده
في النهايه بعثت بسفيره لها الى نياما
المجلس العسكري ممثلا في رئيس وزراه
بدا يستقبل السفراء الغربيين في النيامي
وهناك تحرك اقليمي ايضا ليس فقط على مستوى
مالي وبوركينا فاسو حليفتي النيجر وانما
محاولات
يعني الغرب الافريقي
والبحر فرنسا قواتها وتسحب السفيرها هذا
يعني انتصار للمجموعه العسكريه ويعني
اعتراف بالامر الواقع وبان عوده بازوم
اصبحت مستحيله واصبحت من الماضي يعني ايضا
خساره لفرنسا في النيجره التي تشكل نقطه
ارتكاز رئيسيه لها في المنطقه وكانت يعني
تبني استراتيجيه على ان ما خسرته في ماليو
بوركينا فاسو ستحاول تعويضه عبر النيجر
وعبر حليفها بازو من خلال البحث عن دول
اخرى جديده في منطقه الغرب الافريقي ونسر
قوات عسكريه فرنسيه فيها الان تخسر مجددا
دوله ثالثه وربما تخسر حتى تشاد في مرحله
لاحقا من طنجه محفوظ ولد السالك الكاتبه
الصحفي المختصه في الشؤون الافريقيه شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
قصف جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نقطتي رصد
لحركه حماس في المناطق الحدوديه وسط وشمال
القطاع وقد ادى القصف لتدبير نقطتي الرصد
دون ان يبلغ عن اصابات ونشر نشطون
فلسطينيون صورا لنقطتي الرصد التابعتين
لكتائب القسام في غزه عقب الغارات
الاسرائيليه مساء
هذا واعلنت وزاره الصحه بغزه اصابه سته
شبان فلسطينيين بجروح مختلفه جراء قمع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مظاهرات قرب
الشريط الحدودي الشرقي قطاع غزه واطلقت
قوه الاحتلال الرصاصه والغاز الموسيله
للدموع باتجاه المتظاهرين وقد اشعل الشبان
المشاركون اطارات مطاطيه قرب السياج
الابدي تمديدا بالاعتداءات والاقتحامات
للمسجد الاقصى
في الاثناء اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قرر
تعزيز قوته على الحدود مع القطاع بقوات
اضافيه وذكر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي في
حسابه على منصه اكس انه اجرى تقييما امليا
في منطقه غلاف غزه مع رئيس الاركان وقاده
عسكريين اخرين كما ذكر المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان المهمه الموكله للقوات
الاضافيه التي تقرر ارسالها الى حدود غزه
هي حمايه سياج الامنيه
في الضفه الغربيه شيعه فلسطينيون جثماني
الجثانين الشهيدين اسيد ابو علي وعبد
الرحمن ابو دغش في مخيم نور شمس بطولكرم
وكانت قوات الاحتلال قد اجتاحت مخيمين دور
شمس وطولكرم بعد منتصف الليل بحجه تدمير
عبوات ناسفه جاهزه للتفجير وقد خرجت اليات
الاحتلال الجو خربت الشوارع والبنى
التحتيه وخطوط المياه الرئيسيه في المخيم
قتل وخراب ودمار هذا ما يخلفه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عقب كل عمليه عسكريه ينفذها
اخر العمليات هنا في مخيم نور شمس الشرق
مدينه طولكرم تدمير لما تبقى من شوارعه
وبنا تحتيه في مخيم متهالكا للاجئين
الفلسطينيين مزاعم الاحتلال وجود عبوات
جاهزه للتفجير لكن هذه العبوات محليه
الصنع اعطبت اليه عسكريه واصابت جنديا
وانتقاما قتل الاحتلال الفلسطينيين عبد
الرحمن ابو دغش واسيد جبعاوي اما العائلات
فلا تملك الا الصبر لا تنسوا الاشاره تقول
اجت رصاصه عمر من الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
[تصفيق]
وفي جنازه تقدمها عشرات المقاومين
هدف الفلسطينيون بوحده الصف في الميدان
ومواصله مقاومه ومواجهه الاحتلال الهدف هو
ارام الناس على طرد هؤلاء المقاتلين الهدف
هو القضاء على الحاضر الشعبي للمقاتلين
هنا في هذا الفيلم كل هذا الدمار التي
الذي رايتيه القتل الذي حدث هنا شهداء
اثنين كله الهدف منه هو القضاء على الحاضن
الشعبيه ولكن ايضا بعد كل عمليه عسكريه
يتضح حجم الاثار النفسيه على العائلات
وتحديدا الاطفال اولادنا مش عارفين يناموا
وخايفين
وبتمم قاعدين وبرجوا وبالليل طول الليل
وهم قاعدين مش عارفين يناموا خايفات
البنات والله عندي بنتكي ساخنه اقسم بالله
نفسيتهم تعبانه
ويؤكد الفلسطينيون ان مقاومتهم لن تتوقف
في الوقت الذي تعلو فيه اصوات على منصه
الامم المتحده بضروره حل الدولتين تمارس
ضغوط على الفلسطينيين لوقف مقاومتهم
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي يواصل ليل نهار
قتل الفلسطينيين
وتمغي صح حياتهم الجزيره من مخيم نور شمس
طولكرم
بعلم ان رام الله الدكتور محمد المصري
رئيس المركز الفلسطيني للبحوث والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه الدكتور محمد ماذا تريد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من خلال هذا التصعيد
سواء بالاقتحامات المسجد الاقصى او بهذه
الاعتداءات
مساء الخير لكافه المشاهدين الكرام
دعني ابدا بالقول بانه يعني واهم من يعني
يراهن على انه يكسر اراده الفلسطيني او
قصر مقاومته بالداخل الفلسطيني الجانب
المهم ملكت النظر جميع في هذه اليوم
بالتحديد انه بالرغم من كل القتل والتدمير
وتجريب في البنيه التحتيه ومحاوله تعزل
المقاتلين عن حضرتهم الشعبيه راينا ما
راينا في المسيره الجنازه بعشرات الالاف
وهذا يدل للتمسك الفلسطيني بالمقامه
والاستمرار في مقاومه الاحتلال قبل اول
امس كان نتنياهو في الامم المتحده ورفع
خارطه الشرق الاوسط الجديد ولم تكن فلسطين
موجوده الى مدينه ولا قريه ولا حتى شعب
موجود وبالتالي هذا التعبير عن السياسه
الاحتلالي سراحه الحكومه الفاشيه في تل
ابيب لا يريد الفلسطيني ان يكون موجودا
ومحاوله الضغط وبالتاكيد الضغط اولا
واخيرا على المخيم الفلسطيني في الاسبوع
الاخير كان هناك مخيم بلاطه مخيم جنين
مخيم عقبه جبر مخيم يعني مقيم نور الشمس
وضرب على كل المخيمات الفلسطينيه المخيم
الفلسطيني برمزته الوطنيه وهو دائما خزان
ثورتنا من سنه 1965 حتى الان ولذلك
التركيز عليه ومن اجل انهاء ملف اللاجئين
والقضاء على حق العوده كما نتحدث فيها
دائما كاولويات للشعب الفلسطيني الهدف
الاسرائيلي الاخر وهو هذا الشيء مهم جدا
هو محاوله رجع الفلسطيني حتى يشعر بانه
هناك ينهك من كثر هذه العمليات يوميا وقد
نصبح صباحا او هذه الليله تكون عمليه في
مخيم اقرا وفي مدينه اخرى او في قريه اخرى
لدينا اليوم اخي العزيز 249 شهيد من بدايه
العام حتى الان ولكن
دكتور محمد
ان هذه الحكومه الموصوفه بانها الحكومه
الاكثر تطرفا تفشل حتى الان في تحقيق
اهدافها
نعم هذا هو اردت القول به انه نلاحظ عدد
المقاتلين او المنطاويين او حامله السلاح
بين ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني المقاومه
المسلحه بين مزدوجين اليوم في الضفه
الفلسطيني اصبحت ظهر على نيو اصبحت الان
مكان مكشوف ولكن القول بانه
الاسرائيلي او هذه الحكومه الفاشيه لديها
القدره بكثره الفلسطيني هذا شيئا مستحيلا
ولكن علينا نحن كفلسطينيين ان نتوحد كما
توحدنا في الميدان ان توحد في المستوى
السياسي ويبقى ظهيرنا العربي متماسك خلفنا
ولا نذهب باتجاه اوهام امكانيه حلول
سياسيه من هذا الكيان المحتل ونضع اعتقد
ان شعبنا استقلت الدروس والعبر عبر سنوات
طويله جدا لا يمكن الا ان يكون صامدا في
الميدان ومتصديا لكل هذه قطعه من
المستوطنين نحن نرى الفاشيه بام العين
بمعنى نعاشرهن نراهم بالشوارع يتطاولون
على الارض اليوم كان هناك يمارسون الرقص
حسب الديانه العبريه او التوراه على ابواب
مسجد الاقصى وبالحرم الابراهيمي والاعتداء
على الاسرى والاعتداء ايضا على كمان
حرائرنا في الخليل كان قبل فتره قريبه اقل
من اسبوعين لذلك لا نرى اي مكان لفلسطيني
الا اذا عمل السلاح ودافع عن نفسه هذه
الحاله الدفاعيه الموجوده قد تتحول في يوم
ماله لحاله الشعبيه عامه صحيح هي الان
متمركزه في بعض القرى في بعض المحافظات
ولكنها تمتد افقيا من خلال البطش دوله
الاحتلال وفاشيتو كلما زاد فاشيه كلما زاد
اسرائيل الفلسطيني على المقاومه لان هذا
حب البقاء والتمشق في مكانته في ارضه وهذا
هو ايضا مستقبل فلسطينيين يجب ان يواجهوا
للحظه الاخيره من رام الله الدكتور محمد
المصري رئيس المركز الفلسطيني للبحوث
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك
نقلت وكاله رايترز عن مسؤول الفلسطيني
قوله ان وفدا سعوديا سيزور رام الله خلال
الاسبوع الجاري وانه من المقرر ان يلتقي
بالرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس واضاف
المسؤول الفلسطيني ان المبعوثه السعودي
غير المقيم نايف بن بندر السديري سيراس
الوفد السعودي واشارت رويترز الى ان زياره
الوفد السعودي لرام الله تاتي وسط مساع
دبلوماسيه للتواصل الى اتفاق بين السعوديه
واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
يتصاعد القلق وسط ارمن اقليم ناجورنو
كارباخ من تعرضهم لما يصفونه بانتقام
سلطات اذربيجان اذا بقوا في الاقليم وقد
تفضل بعضهم النزوح ووصلت دفعه اولى منهم
الى الاراضي الارمينيه عبر ممر لاشين
مراسل الجزيره محمود الزئبق من المبر رصد
المشهد
معظم السكان لا يريدون لا يريدون البقاء
في اذربيجان يريدون العوده الى ارمينيا
واريد ان اشير هنا الى ان عمليه التهجير
ليست ليست المراه الاولى التي تجري فيها
التهجير بين ارمينيا واذربيجان عمليات
تهجير تصل الى مليون شخص منذ 30 عاما حتى
الان سبق ان حصلت هجره وهجره معاكسه تهجير
ديموغرافي بين البلدين هي ليست شيئا جديدا
على هذه الحرب المستمره منذ 30 عاما فعليا
المشكله الكبرى هناك التي يغادر بسببها
السكان هي انعدام الثقه يقولون انهم لا
يعلمون ما الذي يمكن ان تقوم به السلطات
الاذربيجانيه في محاسبه السكان اقليم بعد
30 عام من الحرب بعد 30 عام من الاتهامات
في المجازر الجماعيه بعد 30 عام من الحروب
والمعارك هم لا يعرفون هل سيصدر بالفعل
العفو عام هل يمكن الثقه بهذا العفو هل
يمكن ايضا الثقه بضمان القوات الروسيه
لهذه لهذا العفو خاصه ان ارمينيا تتهم
القوات قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه بانها لم
تقم بدورها بمعاهده عام 2020 والذي نص على
ان يبقى هذا الممر ممر لاتشين مفتوحا لكنه
كان مغلقا هذا الممر كان مغلقا وبالتالي
كان هناك اتهامات للضامن الروسي على انه
لا يقوم بدوره بشكل جيد في في هذه
الاتفاقيه الان المخاوف والهواجس الامنيه
نفسها قائمه
في الاثناء قالت وزاره الداخليه
لاذربيجاني انه سيتم ضمان خروج المسلحين
الارمن الذين القوا اسلحتهم بموجب الاتفاق
الاخير من اقليم كاراباخ من جهتها قال
السلطات اقليم كنباخ ان العائلات الراغبه
في مغادره الاقليم الى ارمينيا ستنقل
بواسطه قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه
وفي سياق المتصل جدد رئيس الوزراء
الارميني نيكول بشنيان استعداد بلاده
لاستقبال ارمان كاراباخ اذا اصبحت اقامته
في هذا الاقليم مستحيله بحسب تعبيره
واعتبر بشنيان ان هجمات اذربيجان المتكرره
واغلاق
يثير تساؤلات بشان اهداف بعثه حفظ السلام
الروسيه في اقليم كنبا
الهجمات العديده التي شنتها اذربيجان على
كاراباخ والحصار غير قانوني بممر لاتشين
تثير تساؤلات جديه حول اهداف وغايات وحده
حفظ السلام الروسيه في الاقليم يواجه شعب
كنباخ تهديدات خطيره واذا لم تتم تهيئه
الظروف المناسبه لهم فسوف يضطرون الى
المغادره وستلقى المسؤوليه على عاتقي
اذربيجان وان لم تسفر المفاوضات عن نتائج
فاننا سنستقبل اخواننا واخواتنا اذا اصبحت
اقامتهم في هذا الاقليم مستحيله
واضاف رئيس الوزراء ان المنظمات الارمينيه
التي تشارك فيها بلاده اظهرت عدم فاعليتها
في حمايه امن ومصالح ارمينيا واتهم بشنيان
في خطاب له اليوم حلفاء بلاده باظهار نقاط
ضعفها وتعريض استقرارها الداخلي واملك
الخارجي للخطر وانتهاك سيادتها واستقلالها
وفق تعبيره
تحليل الوضع يظهر ان المنظمات الامنيه
والحلفاء الذين نعتمد عليهم منذ زمن طويل
قد كلفوا بمهمه اظهار ضعفنا واستحاله ان
تكون لشعب ارمينيا دوله مستقله ان
المنظمات الامنيه التي تشارك فيها ارمينيا
غير فعاله في حمايه امن البلاد ومصالحها
وقد شهدنا مظاهر هذه السياسه خلال العقود
الماضيه نحن لا نتفق مع التصريحات والصيغ
التي تشكك في استقلال ارمينيا يبذل بعض
شركائنا مزيدا من الجهود لاظهار ثورتنا
الامنيه وهم الان يعرضون امننا الخارجيه
واستقرارنا الداخليه للخطر عبر انتهاك
اخلاقيات العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
والالتزامات والمعاهدات
في المقابل انتقد وزير الخارجيه روسيا في
مؤتمر الصحفي في نيويورك رئيس الوزراء
الارمني لكل بشنيان واتهم قيادات ارمينيا
بصب الزيت على النار بشان التسويه في
اقليم
حقيقه في ارمينيا كما هو الحال في عدد من
بلدان الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق الاخرى
هناك لوبي قوي لتعزيز مصالح الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وهم يعملون على تقويض
نفوذ روسيا هناك وهذه حقيقه ومن المؤسف ان
القياده الارمينيه تعمل على صب الوقود على
النار على سبيل المثال وقع رئيس وزراء
ارمينيا ورئيس اذربيج برعايه الاتحاد
الاوروبي وثيقه تنص على اعتراف كل منهما
بسلامه اراضي الطرف الاخر داخل حدود عام
1991 وهذا يعني ان كارباخ هي اذربيجان
انتهى
وتشهد العلاقات الروسيه الارمينيه توترا
بدا في تراشق بدا بالتراشق التصريحات بين
المسؤولين في موسكو واي ريفان ويترافق ذلك
مع خطوات في يربان تراها روسيا محاولات
لتقويض نفوذها في ارمينيا
اقليم كاراباخ بيد اذربيجان بمباركه موسكو
خلال 24 ساعه فقط حسم الصراع بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا وهو بعض من ارث الحقبه السوفيتيه
فعلى مدى ثلاثه عقود تواجهت الدوله في
جولات قتال اعقبت سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي
داخل ارمينيا تم 8 يرى ان مصير اقليمي
كاراباخ كان محسوما منذ هزيمه ارمينيا في
حرب خريف 2020 التي استمرت 44 يوما وخلافا
لجوله القتال السابقه فان اللافت هذه
المره ان اذربيجان احكمت سيطرتها على
الاقليم ونزعت سلاح الجماعات الانفصاليه
من ارمن كاراباخ دون اي مقاومه عمليه تذكر
من الحكومه الارمينيه برئاسه نيكول
باشنيان وان طويت صفحته كاراباخ واخرج من
خارطه الصراعات في جنوب القوقاز الا ان
صراعا سياسيا بدا دخانه ينبعث في ريفان
تشعر الحكومه هناك ان خذلت من حلفائها في
الشرق في اشاره ديموسكو يقول رئيس الوزراء
الارميني ان تحالفات ارمينيا الحاليه
اثبتت انها غير مجديه لحمايه امنها
ومصالحها يرى ان ارمينيا تذوقت مراره
الخطا الذي اقترفته حين اعتمدت على روسيا
فقط لبناء امنها الاستراتيجي حديث باشنيان
هذا انما هو تاكيد لما يقال عن خطوات
ارمينيه للخروج من عباءه روسيا والاتجاه
غربا تقيم روسيا قاعده عسكريه لها على
الحدود بين ارمينيا وتركيا هي قاعده 102
في كيومري شمال غربي ارمينيا ويؤمن حرس
الحدود الروسي حدود ارمينيا مع تركيا
وايران تعد ارمينيا عضوا في الاتحاد
الاقتصادي الاوراسي الذي تقوده روسيا ويمص
على التكامل الاقتصادي والسياسي بين
اعضائه ارمينيا عضون ايضا في منظمه معاهده
الامن الجماعي وهي تحالف عسكري تراسه
روسيا تعد روسيا المستثمره الرئيسيه في
ارمينيا منذ عام 2015 باستثمارات بلغت
اربعه مليارات دولار
في يناير الماضي رفضت ارمينيا استضافه
مناورات لمنظمه معاهده الامن الجماعي
لكنها شاركت في مناورات عسكريه مع
الولايات المتحده هذا الشهر ما اثار
استياء موسكو لا يمكن النظر الى التدهور
غير المسبوق والتحول التاريخي في العلاقات
الروسيه الارمينيه بمن ان عن التجاذب
الروسي مع الغرب فليس سرا ان من يحكمون في
ريفان محسوبون على النخبه المواليه للغرب
كما انه ليس سرا توجهات فاشنيان الغربيه
وهو الذي دخل عالم السياسه صحفيا معارضا
لما وصفت بالوصايه الروسيه على ارمينيا في
مايو الماضي طرح رئيس الوزراء الارمني
احتمال انسحاب بلاده من منظمه معاهده
الامن الجماعي تراقب موسكو صدى ما حدث في
كاراباخ على نفوذها داخل يريفان يحذر وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سارغافروف من صعود لوبي
في ارمينيا يحاول تقويض الدور الروسي هناك
لتعزيز مصالح واشنطن وحلفائها
معنى حول هذا الملف من موسكو اسفي
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس ومن
ذكرى رئيس تحرير القسم العربي بوكاله
الانباء الارمنيه اهلا بكم
السيد الدكرم كيف
تصف حاليا العلاقه بين وموسكو
مساء الخير لكم المشاهدين شكرا للاستضافه
العلاقات تاريخيه ما بين الارمينه وروسيا
حليفه متحالفه
اخويه وصلت الى درجه الانصهار الثقافي
الان هناك
مشاكل وهناك عوائق يجب النظر اليها بكل
تجرد
وبكل واقعيه سياسيه
ليست ارمينيا هي التي
في وضع ان تدلي او تطرح ما يجب ان تكون
عليها هذه العلاقات لان موسكو هي البلد
القوى العظمى وهي
في المنطقه هي
هيتكلم عن لوبي داخل
يذهب باتجاه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
نعم
يبدي خيبه امل من موسكو ومن انحيازها خلال
حرب 44 يوم وخلال الهجوم العسكري
الازربيجاني على الحدود على الاراضي
السياديه الارمنيه
وما جرى بعد هذا الهجوم على ارطاقنا
نوف اذا كانت لدى موسكو كما قال وزير
خارجيتها هذه المخاوف بان هناك لوبي داخل
يريفان يذهب باتجاه واشنطن هل من مصلحه
موسكو ان تساهم في اسراع هذا الانتقال من
حديث استراتيجي لموسكو الى حليف استراتيجي
لواشنطن
في الحقيقه نحن مستعدون
للمساعده في حل المشكله
ولكن المشكله ليست لدينا نحن
المشكله هي في القياده الارمنيه نفسها
فمنذ البدايه كان خطا كبيرا
ارمينيا في الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث بداوا
عمليه
انتفاضه او حديقه الجانب ضد المواطنين في
المواطنهم في اذربيجان حاولت موسكو ان
تتوسطه
وذلك في حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي ومنذ سنوات
طويله استمرت محاولات الوساطه
ولكن
[موسيقى]
الارمن او في
ناغورني كارابا لم يشاؤوا اذا
القبول بالوساطه ودفعوا بمواطني اذربيجان
الى الخروج من هذا الاقليم اذا كانت
واعذرني على المقاطعه عندما يقول السيد
بشنيان موجها كلامه لمن وصفهم بالحلفاء
والكلام موجه لموسكو يقول بانكم قد ان
موسكو عرضت بلاده وابارك نقاط ضعفها
وتعريض استقلالها الداخلي وامنها الخارجي
الخطر وانتهاك سيادتها واستقلالها وفق
تعبيره هذا الكلام لا يوجه الى حليف او
انه لن يبقى حليفا كما كان
الى التحالف او ان نبقى حلفاء سنبقى حلفاء
الشعب
الارماني بالنسبه السيد هو يعتبر الان
خائنان لدى الغالبيه العظمى من شعبه السنه
الماضيه زرت ارمينيا وعقدت اجتماعا مع
الرئيس
او سمعتوا ان الكثير من الارمن لا يريدون
المشاركه في اي حروب
ولا يريدون
اذا من قيادتهم او اقل تظاهرون ضد قدهم
والان يتظهرون ضد روسيا يريدوننا ان نشارك
في هذا النزاع او ان ننزل في الميدان
المعركه ونقاتل لا هذا
سوف لن نقوم به سوف لن نتدخل عسكريا
وبالتالي
هذا يعبر عن عدم رساله واضحه من قبل موسكو
وهنا اسال ضيفي من ريفان
كابويان هل هذه هي الرساله الموجهه من
موسكو الى يريفاند اذا اقتربتم من واشنطن
ستدفعون الثمن كالذي جرى في الناغور
انا لست بموضع ما تدليه موسكو او او افهم
الرسائل ولكن الانشاء
[موسيقى]
بتقدير متواضع الشعب والحكومه لا يريدان
معاداه موسكو ولا شعب الروسي ولا
السياسه الروسيه هي موضع نقاش لان
ضيفك الكريم من موسكو يقول ان الارمن في
اذربيجان انطفدوا هذا غير مفهوم لانه
الارمن تعرضوا لحملات اباده ولتطهير ارقي
في
المهم ولكن اذا اذا لم نتحدث عن رفاق
نفسها اذربيجان هاجمت على ارمينيا واحتلت
الان بهذه الدقيقه محتله 150 كيلومتر مربع
من اراضيها السياديه المعترفه دوليا حسب
واتفق الاتحاد السوفيتي وروسيا
تعرف هذا في اتفاقيه المعاطى ان
اراضي السياديه الارمنيه في اتحاد
الاحتلال
الازربيجاني
ومعاده الامن الجماعي لم يتدخل ويقول ان
ليس لدي شخص
ما عسى ان تفعلوا ارمينيا من يربان كبيان
رئيس تحرير القسم العربي بوكاله انباء
الارمينيه شكرا لك وكذلك لضيفي من موسكو
السفير
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس
[موسيقى]
اكد شرطه كوسوفو ان قوتها قتلت ثلاثه
مسلحين وسيطرت على دير تحصن فيه اخرون
كانوا ضمن مجموعه شنت هجوما على موقع
للشرطه شمالي البلاد وقتلت ضابطه شرطه
عندما كانت السلطات اعلنت ان مجموعه من
المسلحين الملثمين قطعوا طريقا محليا في
احدى القرى الشماليه وبداوا باطلاق النار
عشوائيا بدورها ابدت قوه النيتو في
الاقليم استعدادها للتدخل تفاصيل في
التقرير التالي
حادث خطير وقع عند الحدود بين صربيا
وكوسوفو شرطه كوسوفو تعلن عن تعرض وحداتها
لهجوم مسلح من قبل ملثمين يستقلون مركبتين
ثقيلتين وصلوا الى قريه بنيسكا شمال
البلاد وبداوا باطلاق النار على وحدات
الشرطه
فتوالت ردود الفعل السياسيه رئيسه كوسوفو
وصفت الهجوم بالارهابي المدبر وقال رئيس
الحكومه ان الجريمه المنظمه تهاجم كوسوفو
اكثر من عقدين مره على انتهاء الحرب ولم
يستقر السلام في كوسوفو بعد سياسيا تتلبد
الاجواء بحالات تصعيد داخلي بين العرقيات
ومع الجوار تحديدا مع صربيا حالات توتر
بدت في الاونه الاخيره اكثر تكرارا
جذور الازمه متشابكه تعود للعقد الاول من
القرن العشرين تفاقمت مع انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي والحرب الدمويه في البلقان بعدها
بسنوات عام 2008 اعلن البرلمان في كوسوفو
استقلال جمهوريه كوسوفو وكان على صربيا
تطبيع علاقتها مع كوسوفو لكنها رفضت
الاعتراف بالجمهوريه واعتبرتها اقليما
منشقا عن بيل جراند تم الاعتراف بكوسوفو
من قبل 97 دوله في الامم المتحده
واثنتين وعشرين دوله من الاتحاد الاوروبي
في ايار مايو الماضي جرت انتخابات محليه
اعتبرت مثيره للجدل وسط مقاطعه واسعه من
صرب كوسوفو شمال البلاد
في تلك الانتخابات اقترع الالبان ما ادى
الانتخاب رؤساء مجالس محليه من الالبان في
مناطق ذات غالبيه صربيه
غضب الصرب واعتبروها محاوله لطردهم من
كوسوفو حسب وصفهم وبدت واحده من اسوا
الاضطرابات في شمال كوسوفو منذ سنوات مع
خروج مظاهرات ووقوع اعمال شغب عنيفه نفذها
متظاهرون الصرب
وتتهم الصربيا بتحريض الصرب كوسوفو على
تحدي السلطات برشتينا تدخل المجتمع الدولي
في وساطه بين بلغراد وبرشتينا قبلت
بموجبها كوسوفو الغاء نتائج الانتخابات
وحل المجالس خفتت الازمه لكن من الواضح
انها لم تنتهي
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر محليه في ليبيا الى فرق
الانقاذ انتشرت نحو 300 جثه من مناطق
بحريه مختلفه وبينما يقترب عدد المتوفين
المسجلين من 4000 شخص تواجه السلطات
الليبيه صعوبات في تحديد هويات الموتى
خاصه مع مرور الوقت ونقص المعدات والوسائل
اسبوعان مر على كارثه السيول في الشرق
الليبي وما تزال فرق الانقاذ تصل الليل
بالنهار بحثا عن جثث الضحايا تحت الطم
والركام وفي مياه البحر المتلاطمه وفق
مصادر محليه في ليبيا فان الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه سجلت انتشال فرق الغوص
نحو 300 جثه من مناطق بحريه مختلفه لا
سيما مدينه درنه شبه المدمره العثور على
مزيد الجثث يرفع عداد القتل في تلك
المناطق المنكوبه كل ساعه وحين انه الان
يقارب 4000 شخص وهذا العدد يتعلق فقط
بالذين سجلتهم وزاره الصحه قبل دفنهم ولا
تعرف على وجه الدقه اعداد الذين دفنوا
عشوائيا وفي مقابر جماعيه مخافه انتشار
الاوبئه كما لا يمكن تحديد اولئك
المفقودين وهم الاف منهم من جرفتهم السي
ول الى البحر واخرون دفنوا تحت الانقاض
التي تغطي احياء بكاملها في درنه
ومع مرور الوقت تتعقد مهمه الجميع ففرق
الاغاثه تواجه تحدي الوصول الى الجثث
البعيده في عمق المياه وتحت ركام المباني
المنهاره اما الجهات الطبيه والعدليه
فامامها معضله تحديد هويات الموتى وتلك
دونها عقبات فنيه
ولوجيستيه وسواها وعلى الصعيد الاغاثي
يستمر تدفق المساعدات المحليه والعربيه
والدوليه الى درنه والمدن المجاوره حيث
تسببت الفيضانات في نزوح اكثر من 43 الف
شخص بحسب احدث احصاء للمنظمه الدوليه
للهجره
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه اعلنت
الوصول نحو ثمان سفن واكثر من 70 طائره
محمله بالمعونات من 24 بلدا حيث حطت خلال
الساعات الماضيه طائره مساعدات صينيه
وطائرتان قطريتان في مطار بنينه في مدينه
بنغازي
معنى منا مصرات الدكتوره هناء الفايدي
الناطقه باسم الهلال الاحمر الليبي في
مصرات اهلا بك دكتوره هناء دكتور هناء كيف
تتعاملون مع كل هذه التحديات خاصه ما تعلق
منها بتحديد هويات المتوفين
اهلا بك اخي طبعا هذه التحديات لا تخفى
على احد التحديات
نتيجه حتى الجغرافيه المكان الذي حدثت فيه
هذه السيول وهذه وهذا الاعسار فهذه
التحديات كثيره ان هي منطقه اولا جبليه
وعلى حدود ساحليه
التربه فيها طينيه فانجرفت اغلبها اغلب
الجثث انطمت تحت الانقاض وتحت الطمي هذا
الوادي وفي المعظم طبعا والاغلبيه العظمى
هي التي جرفها الوادي او السير الى البحر
جغرافيه حتى تضاريس البحر جغرافيتا صعبه
شويه في مدينه درنه الليبيه الشرقيه
الجغرافيه صعبه جدا لان هي تابعه لجغرافيه
جبليه
فكانت تواجه صعوبات الفرق الانتشار نتحدث
عن فريق الهلال الاحمر فرع مصراته توجهتنا
نحن لدينا خبره في الانتشار الخبره توجهنا
الصعوبات نتيجه تضاريس هذا المكان فكان
يتم الدعم عن طريق الفرق الدوليه باستعمال
المروحيات العموديه لتحديد اين الجثث
طافيه او اي متواجده هذه جثث ومن تم يتم
الحركه اليها عن طريق الفرقاطه زروق ويتم
جلب هذه الجزر فالاليه صعبه جدا في نتيجه
تضاريس هذا المكان طبعا نتيجه اصلا حتى
الامكانيات الضعيفه للفرق الفرق الانقاذ
الموجوده في المكان
طيب عند انتشال هذه الجثث كما تابعنا في
التقرير هل متوفره الامكانيات للتعرف على
هويات هذه الجثث خاصه وان للاسف هذا
الفيضان وهذا السيل يعني اباد ربما عائلات
باكملها وبالتالي التعرف على هذه الجثث
ومن ثم اجراءات دفنها
طبعا هي سلسله العمل الكيفيه لسبب بها
العمل انها هي الفرق الانتشار والانقاذ
فقط تقوم بعمليه الانتشار ومن ثم تسلم الى
الجهات المختصه في اخذ البيانات
وعينات الدين اي وعمليات التسجيل البيانات
والدفن فكانت الفرق الانقاذ طبعا العمل في
تراتبيه في العمل ان فرق تنقذه فرق تقوم
بعمليه تسجيل البيانات وفرق تاخذ العينات
وفرق تقوم بعمليات الدفن
فهذه كل يعني كل جهه كانت مختصه في
بالنسبه كاهلال احمر كانت فقط تطرق يعني
نقف عند لحظه او يقف عملنا عند الانتشار
وتسليم بجث لجهات المختصه
شكرا
هناء الفايدي الناطق باسم الهلال الاحمر
الليبي في مصراته
[موسيقى]
عمق قرار برنامج الاغذيه العالميه للامم
المتحده بخفض المساعدات الغذائيه للاجئين
ازمه السوريين في مخيمي الزعتري والازرق
شمال شرقي الاردن ويقلص القرار الجديد
امدادات الغذاء لنحو 120 الفا من اللاجئين
السوريين
ما عادت لقمه العيش سهله المنال في شتات
السوريين يشعر اللاجئ يوسف النجار بالقلق
حيال توفير الغذاء لعائلته عقب قرار اممي
بتقليص المساعدات
ولا تلوح في الافق بعد سنين طويله من
اللجوء ومن دون دخل للنجار اي بارقه امل
حتى وان كانت تفصيله بضعه كيلومترات عن
بلاده
ذهبت الحكومه الاردنيه والمنظمات الدوليه
على تقديم الاغذيه والادويه للاجئين
السوريين لكن تقليص تلك المساعدات براي
لاجئين سيطوي مرحله كانت فيها الوجبات
ثلاثا نحاول ندبر حالنا يعني بدل ما ناكل
ثلاث وجبات اليوم صرنا ناكل وجبتين نتاقلم
قاعدين ولكن بالفعل حال ماساويه يعني قرار
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي يقلل حصه الغذاء
للاجئ الواحد في المخيمات من 32 دولارا في
الشهر الى 21 دولارا اعتبارا من شهرين
اغسطس وسبتمبر وسبق لمنظمات غير حكوميه
انقلت خدمات الصحه ايضا
نحن قلقون حقا من ان نقص التمويل الذي
نشهده حاليا قد يؤدي الى تقويض الانجازات
التي حق للاجئين السوريين على مدى عشر
سنوات
نقص التمويل وتزايد اعباء اللاجئين
والمخاوف من توطينهم تجعلوا الاردن في
موقف معقد ومقلق لاسيما ان العوده
ليست متاحه رغم التطمينات الصادره من دمشق
عبر الحدود بين عمان ودمشق ينشط تهريب
المخدرات والسلاح فيما تنعدم اسباب الحياه
في الداخل السوري براي اللاجئين يبدل
الاردن رغبه حقيقيه في اعاده اللاجئين
طوعيا لكن اللقاءات الدبلوماسيه الاخيره
بين عمان ودمشق لم تقدم اي حلول من طرف
المسؤولين السوريين لحل هذه الازمه ان
مستقبل اللاجئين هو في بلدهم وحل قضيه
اللاجئين يكون في عوده اللاجئين الى بلدهم
وهذا يستدعي كما قال مع للاخ ان يكون
هنالك مستلزمات هذا العيش من هنا جهدنا
المستمر مستقبل اللاجئين في مهب الريح كما
يقول معظم قاطني الزعتري خبز النجار اصبح
انجازا صباحيا يتارجح على دراجته الهوائيه
كما تتارجح احلام اللاجئين وخلفهم زوجاتهم
بعوده تبدو بعيده
حسن الشوبك الجزيره مخيم الزعتري في
المفرق شرقيه الاردن
[موسيقى]